an HD camera the size of a credit card
and eyeball pillows it's episode 11 of
loot
Joey Roth has created a mouse made of
felt that feels like a mouse and here
are some book marks Mark Zuckerberg Mark
Twain Karl Marx you you get it okay
here's a tool to look inside your own
ears she can't believe it
let's talk science tease quasars are
far-out I'm into a hydrogen bondage
wanted dead and/or alive Schrodinger's
cat money is the root of all evil and
this which is what gluttonous
mathematicians say if you'd rather be
formal we're a pixelated dress now
they're just for show but you can buy
this squid skarner not real enough we'll
grab some jewelry made out of actual
hair balls contact Heidi and her and her
cats we'll make custom pieces for you
here are some fun dog bone shaped paper
clips except when you use them they kind
of look like yeah these Katamari flats
were made by an artist and aren't for
sale
but these military Manolo Blahniks lined
with bullets are now if you've already
got a pair up the caliber with that 19's
bullets Space Pen it's pressurized
writes upside down underwater and even
over oil and grease now if you like
metal pins but hate regular ink that 19
also carries a metal pen that's right a
pen that writes in metal the tip leaves
behind a shiny trail of actual metal
that's nearly impossible to erase
continue to be awesome with their
medieval weapon pushpins these look like
the old boring ones but deadly and
insane if you want to be cuter grab
their cookie melts these look delicious
but are actually wax you can melt to
give your room a fresh-baked cookie
smell time to learn pop chart lab is
famous for its incredible infographic
posters they've got giant charts of
famous haircuts and music a taxonomy of
superpowers rap names and their most
simple the migratory patterns of fresh
Prince's speaking of fresh and dice in
the mirror if you want some make them
20-sided think geek also has a Dali
clock that appears to melt
shelf and a warped mug that's actually
perfectly shaped to sit on your lap or
your knee
typography up your style with these
iPhone skins built out of famous text
from Star Wars Episode five The Simpsons
and Ghostbusters harebrained offers a
t-shirt of a skull made out of kittens
and if you want something free go to
their website and download the free
skulls are for [ __ ] wallpaper
subscribe to Vsauce 2 for more and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]